well i'm joined now by matthew taylor
chief executive of the nhs confederation
thank you very much indeed for joining
us uh blackpool the latest nhs trust to
declare a critical incident what are you
hearing about how serious this situation
is
so the situation is serious across the
whole country nhs england um has
declared a level four
uh
state of um uh incidents for the health
service as a whole in relation to kobed
and then we have
uh local trusts uh declaring a moment of
critical critical incident now
what that means will vary from place to
place and it's primarily a way for local
nhs leaders to be able to indicate
that
they are very stretched that they need
all staff who are available to come in
to work
and that all resources are going to have
to be focused on the things that are
most urgent and pressing
of course declaring a critical incident
in nhs trust actually means that you can
you could draw on more resources and
more support what are you hearing about
just how short staffed some hospitals
are
and indeed how exhausted some staff are
well we've got a number of things
interacting here haven't we we have
these staff most of them have been
working for two years in this very
difficult situation
we've now got um around kind of 10 staff
absence is what i'm hearing and that
most staff absent now now is omicron so
omicron on its own
is the single biggest freeze is the
biggest reason for staff absence bigger
than all other reasons added together
and then you've got on top of this of
course
the rising rate of hospitalization and
um the figures we've been reading about
in the last few days have been
influenced by christmas new year bank
holidays we're really only going to know
what's happening in those underlying
trends about the number of people
needing hospital care
over the next few days and of course
that comes on top of the fact that we've
got two years of pent-up demand in the
health service people waiting for
operations and appointments and some of
those people getting very sick
and and mr taylor what more would uh
help the nhs to relieve them of this
workforce issue potentially reducing the
isolation period what would you want to
hear from the government when they hold
this news conference later today
i think there's a number of things that
we'd like our members would like to be
considered first of all it is really
important that nhs and care staff are
prioritized for
availability of tests this test
availability is an issue and
unless we can get our health and care
staff to work and of course if you can
do the test it means you can return to
work slightly earlier
we also think has happened at an earlier
stage in this uh pandemic that we need
to encourage uh medical students and
trainees to help out uh on awards and
that's something we've done before we we
think it's necessary may be necessary
again and we need to continue to look at
the data in relation to how long the
isolation period is the government
reduced it from ten days to seven days
not
in a sense to to to allow a higher risk
but because the science showed that if
you could do a natural flow test on day
six and seven that was as safe as ten
days isolation so if the science
suggests that you can cut that further
well that would be good but of course
the last thing we want is people who are
still infected with this virus back in a
clinical setting
of course united lincolnshire hospitals
nhs trust was the first to declare a
major incident are you hearing of any
others that may be next
uh i think there are a few and we've
heard about uh blackpool um i i i it
when a trust declares a critical
incident like this it is an important
moment it's an important signal to
local staff to local people about what
they have to do but
i i i wouldn't want to exaggerate the
difference between these incidents and
the general position of most parts of
the health service right now so
you know there is no part of the health
service that isn't under immense strain
and that's why it's really important
that whether it's public policy in terms
of how we manage the situation where all
the individual responsibility that we
show
that we do everything we possibly can
over the next few weeks to minimize
unnecessary pressure on our health
service
and does this mean that we're going to
see non-urgent care cancelled
i think it's inevitable
uh that in many parts of the country
this combination of rising hospital
hospitalization rates rising staff
absence
is going to mean that anything that
isn't very urgent is going to be put on
the back burner and of course there's
still the issue
of the fact that people who've got code
need to be separated out from other
patients because of the infection risk
we are seeing the development of this
surge capacity so this is facilities
being set up
and near hospitals often in car parts to
create extra beds and that's welcome
that can help with separating patients
out but the problem is if you have a
shortage of staff if that's the kind of
rate limiting factor well you can create
extra temporary beds if you've got no
one to staff them it doesn't make a huge
amount of difference
okay matthew taylor chief executive of
the nhs confederation thank you very
much indeed for joining us today thank
you